joining us in the man cave the NBC
Sports Premier League host Rebecca Lowe
big match later today at 3:00 Eastern
right here on NBCSN Manchester United
always bringing drama against Arsenal
and then Saturday the Premier League fan
fest oh I love you when you guys do the
fan fest you'll be in New York at the
South Street Seaport that'll be a 7:00
a.m. until 5:00 p.m.
yeah and some meet-and-greet come out
and say hello to Rebecca Lowe that's it
just before we talk about the fan fest
you know you said this is the man cave
yeah you guys have been talking about
Sleepless in Seattle yeah and it smells
of a 15 year old girl's bedroom in here
wait a minute you're the one that
brought in Victoria's Secret body spray
my signature scent what Victor is that
secrets listing what's it called love
spell love spell love spell yeah I'm
wearing it for many a year see all those
years that I've known you I did not know
that you had love spell on okay Cologne
on men yeah oh yeah you like it
yeah uh well yeah I do when my husband
was I'm like yes every day I like
Cologne on me okay but I have Cologne on
right now I know it was rather
overpowering she called you a cuddle yes
you did
yeah or a hug it's a cuddle well what's
the difference
cuddle feels like it's a little bit
longer it was a hug - yeah definitely a
hug
yeah no no although we've shared a meal
we've had a number of meals no no I
actually shared your meal I ate off your
plate I was so hungry and then I was
like you're gonna eat that and you're
like no I'm gonna dive in I say no no no
go ahead I know you may have said
something else no no we can cuddle go
ahead all right how you been really good
I'm really good we go crazy wheat likes
a fan fest coming up this weekend we got
loads of games going on this week and
it's just it's a busy week okay if you
were going to look at Manchester United
and explain Manchester
United with all the drama coaches yep
they're not great this year no but but
like you say to explain that to somebody
maybe who isn't
okay with what's been going on
Manchester United are the biggest club
in world football arguably maybe up
there with Real Madrid and Barcelona but
many will believe even bigger their
history is amazing
they've won everything a number of times
and they had a manager for 20 almost 27
years in Sir Alex Ferguson who was the
best of the best of the best
he leaves five and a half years ago and
they haven't recovered and so this
season they're sitting in eighth I think
it is going into today's game this is
the team in a club that is used to
winning silverware and they're now
managed by a man in joso Mourinho who's
also won everything but is he now past
his prime he's crazy he is a little
crazy at the moment and he loves himself
yeah I mean he does and he called
himself the special one 15 years ago he
came to England he's like I'm not from
the bottle I'm the special one and he
was and he turned out to be however I
think the specialness has kind of gone a
little bit and he's in real trouble but
he is he's great TV and quite frankly
that's all I care yes it's about content
so you're happy to have him but it's
Manchester City maybe the Golden State
Warriors of the Premier League yeah yes
so Manchester City I like that they've
got the most amount of weight you live
in Northern California yeah where the
Golden State Warriors are play a
basketball team yeah yeah they play in
San Francisco right no no yes yes yeah I
don't live there though I live quite far
away plus you know there's a lot of
other things to keep an eye on in
American sport I'm also watching NFL on
a regular basis NHL MLB so I can't just
focus on the Golden State worries but
yes Manchester City are similar they are
they are the juggernaut of the Premier
League so that makes it even worse
because for years Manchester City were
not very good they were even like two
divisions below Manchester United a man
United never had to worry about Man City
all of a sudden within the same city it
shifted in San Francisco's there another
NBA team or is it just Golden State
Warriors like is there another
Sacramento
yeah but that's not this thing okay so
there isn't really a comparison you guys
already have tend to have one team per
city right you don't do what we do where
we have man city and man united own like
New York you have yeah be like that oh
yeah Brooklyn any of the names but if it
was in baseball you'd be like the
Yankees suddenly becoming rubbish really
really rubbish and then the Mets I mean
can you just check out the knowledge
suddenly becoming really good yeah yeah
I don't ever happen again like we didn't
think this would have happened and it's
happened so yeah but you can just have a
billionaire go out and buy everybody and
you can't but that is true that is true
but we did have leicester city your team
like Chester yeah when the Premier
League title two years ago not really
based so much on money so stuff can
happen in sport that you really don't
expect and that's the beauty of it how
do the locals feel about when Americans
come over you've had John Henry as an
owner let's see Kroenke stan kroenke
Lerner yeah he got roughed up and Ellis
short up at Sunderland not so good so
there's been good and bad I mean John
Henry's a brilliant owner and I think a
lot live for fans have been delighted
with everything that he's done the
glazes are not as popular some of the
other owners have not done such a good
job but I think the likes of John Henry
has done such a such a he's made such an
impact at a such a huge world wide known
club that it's done the American even
coming into football the world of good
who was the most popular player in the
Premier League right now not the best
the most popular you mean kind of from a
neutral point of view probably somebody
like David silver of Manchester City or
I mean Kevin de Bruyne knows injured but
he's super popular and as out of Chelsea
they people know Salah masala yeah
masala nice knowledge damn Oh salad I
don't know well okay who's the best
player oh gosh I mean it's really really
subject like if there was no price tag
it was an open draft gosh well it
depends on age as well probably
Edna's odd of Chelsea probably because
he's young enough to still be super
expensive
David David Silver's like 32 so he's
coming towards the end of his career so
there's an open draft he probably
wouldn't go first but he's he's insane
Edna's odd probably and Kevin de Bruyne
oh does anybody ever say Cain instead of
Harry Kane like every time he scores
[Music]
he's just like you gotta say both names
he's so good you got to say both names
no but you shouldn't he be able to stand
with with just one name but because it's
one syllable on a I mean I'm no I'm no
commentator but Asghar lie why when
you're shouting a name Cain will get
lost
I missed you Harry yeah Prince yeah cuz
he is basically a prince of English
football also it's more popular Harry
Kane or Prince Harry Mason question
amazing quit dead heat right now Wow
because Harry's married Megan who we
love by the way and then you guys have
accepted her we've always accepted we're
having a royal baby American royal baby
I mean that's that's that's mega so
Harry loves me we love Megan Harry Las
Vegas that's good
but Harry Kane is English football
sweetheart and actually arguably his
wife's name isn't Sally I'm on fire a
foot on this Cologne I'm a different gun
how's your love spell working here your
Victoria I think yeah yeah football's
more I think football is very slightly
more popular than the royal family so
probably Harry K what is the state of
the Premier League you know as far as
has it gotten to where it's going to get
no I think what makes it grow because
the NFL is trying to go into Mexico
trying to go into London yeah the NBA is
expanded getting players from all over
the world here so what's the Premier
League do that's the next step as far as
a business strategy that's a good point
I think probably America is a big part
of the business strategy and I think
it's making great ground here but it's
always gonna be one of the hardest
places to crack because of your other
Hugh
sports it don't really exist so much
elsewhere around the world but why don't
we get a Premier League team here
because we keep talking about putting an
NFL team there that's when it gets a
little bit difficult okay don't come and
take off
it's true football traditionalists I
don't think I'll ever ever ever allow
that happen you have to remember dad how
about if we take Crystal Palace cuz they
double mean that is double Crystal
Palace is so bad that we would take
Crystal Palace here and we would make
them better
the pride of South London yeah we might
hate them no you just leave my palace
where they are we'll give you
Jacksonville Jaguars rubbish and then
you give us crystal pile I feel like we
always seem to have a Jacksonville
Jaguar game on at Wembley because
they're just like they're the rubbish
team that no Minds if they go away for a
week no and it's a jugulars right all
the Jaguars
well but the English pronounce you are
yeah and we say it's Jaguar and I have
to say on air Jaguar which I find
incredibly difficult and sometimes my
research or when I've got the promo has
to spell it out and actually like put
dashes in between yeah you can you still
pronounce things in you know you know
when I'm pronouncing American things I
have to do it the American Way that's
only white like st. Louis no st. Louis I
said st. Louis once st. Louis pausing
between is st. Louis yes what other
American not true Dom is always should
be not your dog
but have to say oh I said we need peg
the other week and everyone just put
their head in their hands like what is
she saying well that's it's Winnipeg but
apparently would it book yeah yeah it's
like Birmingham is Birmingham Birmingham
yeah yeah Birmingham Birmingham yeah but
you guys do have a Birmingham we do mama
you know that's fair enough cuz that's
how you say it but if you were gonna
come to Birmingham you've got to call it
Birmingham or Middlesbrough it's
Middlesbrough and not Middlesbrough
but you guys say like Foxborough you
work where the Reds know where the New
England Patriots yes yeah we would say
Foxborough so I have to make sure that
if I'm doing a promo about Sunday Night
Football Foxborough I say Poirot
it's very calm
NBC Sports just launched the pilot of a
show on YouTube called the lowdown and
it starts usually name
yeah the lowdown it's a combination of a
highlight recap and a spin on the
Premier League studio show where instead
of asking questions Rebecca answers them
the format in length of the show were
built with YouTube's platform in mind
it's a weekly show released each Sunday
is is this show a part of that show the
lowdown is what show part of that show
you being on this show no I don't think
so
but why aren't we doing this show as
part of the low-down with you being on
this show that would be a would be a
hybrid of amazing shows right there but
I don't know actually it's a good point
I because the low down is something I do
in the studio after I'm done on a Sunday
with all the goals from the day and the
day before and then football questions
I'm not sure where you've to be honest
and I'm not sure you'd make the edit do
you think that you could beat up one of
the men in Blazers if you had to beat
them up one of them Roger it feels like
you could I could probably take ROG and
I think he'd be ok with that because
Michaels kind of looks like sneakier
yeah a little kind of around the corner
like not always got Rogers just there
because Michaels sort of a poor man's
Jason Statham yeah I would go with that
I think you'd be I think it'd be
delighted with that I mean who wouldn't
with what a poor man's Jason state-o or
Jason Statham its Jason Statham the
best-looking guy in England who is
Daniel Craig no David Beckham but he's
not there wait what about posh and like
that they were in LA did they sell that
crib no they have cribs everywhere they
do like you Dan cribs around the world
so they have a place in LA which they
come at you but they're based in London
their children go to school in London
because you know he's a proper Brit he
just can't
he loves it ok is George Clooney in
London now that's a good question I
think George and his wife have a place
in I want to say Oxfordshire or
Gloucestershire which is a beautiful
part of like a couple of hours outside
London so they have a big pad on the
outskirts of London ok how much time in
my allotted yeah before I can say I have
an English accent how long can I live in
England where I can sit and you know
like Madonna Paltrow I mean like over
the weekend they got any no you can't do
that you got to be I gotta do it gotta
be authentic own your American accent is
so thick
oh it is but oh sure so that by the time
you would pick up an ink I mean we're
talking 15 to 20 years I would suggest
until you're full-on Brit is the
princess is Megan Markel developing a
British accent once you become royal you
kind of don't speak up you're not
allowed to you don't do a lot of
interviews you know I I really like
Prince Harry ice legend like if I wanted
to be one of the walls like Prince Harry
would have been the guy yeah because
there's no pressure on you know you know
you're really gonna be king let's be
honest you're still Prince and you still
a forefront
yeah goof around have a bit of fun but
still be close enough to be important
you know what I mean
so he used to be a bit he wasn't ever as
popular as Prince William because Prince
William is the future King people loved
him and he was like a real good as gold
kind of boy but everyone has suddenly
late to the party developed this love
for Harry and also Harry's just gone and
got an American girl and we're all
absolutely in love with her and he's
just a proper led my wife was early on
with Prince Harry she said he's a
good-looking guy and I go wait the
redheaded one right so there's been a
swap at some point in the last 10 years
it's gone from Prince William because
I'm similar aged to Prince William and
my friends and I we used to try to work
out where he was gonna go to university
so maybe we could go as well maybe did
you ever marry my princess no I didn't
stalk him but I did we did investigate
he went to son Andrews and I'm sorry I
can't go to Sandra's about nothing to do
it's I can't do anything what am I gonna
do you just go to a bar yeah I know but
since Scotland I was in Norwich the long
way away so I gave up being a princess
by that point Prince William was very
much like he was a hottie dad Patrick in
my early 20s a hottie yeah and then all
of a sudden he's been lapped by his
brother and now Prince Harry is a dish
he is an English dish does Prince
William get a hairpiece
it's to taste I mean we know it's too
late
it would be it would be it'll be
terrible Wayne Rooney I think Rooney's
had implants yeah he could get employed
the problem is it would be you call them
plugs yeah huh yeah that that's what
they are I thought they were hair
implants no they're called plugs that's
what the room dog calls it are you mate
well he's now he's now here in the
United States but he's the room dog he's
the rune dog does he be on the show on
the show did we I think we were trying
to have him at the all-star game yeah we
came very close to your schedule his
we've had back him like three times in
here on this chair no not not in the
chair really on the show then if he just
been on the phone or yeah he was
actually okay if it's an open draft
Prince William or backpacks
he's like Beck's isn't like the people's
royalty you know he's he's done so much
for our country he's the Pele of look
yeah he all for sure and he's gonna be
so David Beckham within five years
sir Davis so David and lady Victoria she
gets to okay so she he's knighted yeah
and then would she get a lady or as if
she got the honor and she became you
have Beck's cell number yeah I got it
yeah excellent well what do we get my
husband says it's okay that I'm in love
with it oh it is he says it's the only
one I'm allowed to be in love with is
David Beckham also we had the same
nickname backs in backs Polly bring in
David Beckham
[Applause]
Rebecca wakes up at 3:00 a.m. on the
weekend and is asleep somewhere around
7:30 and if she's not then she's been
bad yeah well I have to get my sleep it
I'm a big sleeper I have to get my sleep
in to do my crazy long you're away from
your son Eddie so you're able to how
how's my accent when I say teddy
oh very oh yeah just Teddy Teddy no it's
too high down the octave
got to drop it let's drop it teddy
that's it we have us gone American again
yeah dead how's my Harry Kane
that's not bad okay thank you thank you
I'll come in and do highlights with you
oh my goodness do you when I came on
your show that was there was a player
that I really liked the name of what's
his name incredible name I got reminded
of it the other day anyway and I and you
were like no stop nothing to do with it
what are you talking about now we've
already seen three touchdowns you're
talking about oh it's a big match later
today right here on NBCSN Manchester
United and Arsenal you throw out the
records when they get together but this
Saturday you can come out in C Rebecca
Lowe
it's a meet and greet it's the Premier
League fan fest this is a big deal from
7:00 a.m. until 5:00 p.m. and the South
Street Seaport matches throughout the
day on the networks of NBC south streets
quite hard to say but that's where you
pause yeah you did
so South Street Seaport been used South
Street Seaport
yeah Seaport people and if you ever get
to Winnipeg
bison Louie yes it's great to see thank
you for stopping by for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]